I'm going to show you how to run
background tasks in App Engine
applications using cues when a
conference is created you can imagine
that there might be a variety of tasks
that need to be executed such as
starting the process to book the venue
creating agenda organizing catering and
sending a confirmation email to the
organizer you'd want to do all of these
tasks in the background rather than
trying to complete everything before the
create conference function returns in
this exercise we're going to use the
default task queue to send a
confirmation email like this one when
someone creates a conference the
learning goal is to understand how to
use task queues but you could imagine
that there are many other tasks that
need to be completed when a new
conference is created to execute a task
in the background using a task queue the
first thing you need to do is define the
work to be done it's up to you to write
the code to execute the task this can be
in a servlet or in an end points
function it just needs to be somewhere
that can be accessed by URL another
thing you're going to need to do is to
configure the queue and you do that in Q
dot XML if you're using the default cute
you actually don't have to do any
configuration but if you're using
anything other than all the defaults
you're going to need to configure your Q
and Q dot XML so here's an example of
the content of Q dot XML you have the Q
entries element that contains a Q
element for every cue that you want to
configure specify the name of the queue
and the rate that it operates that and
there's a bunch of other parameters you
can specify as well and then you're
going to need to write the code to add
the task to the queue you need to start
by getting the cue and you use the queue
factory to get a queue if you want the
default queue then you just call get
default queue on it if you've configured
a Q and Q dot XML and you want to use
that queue then you call the get Q
method on q factory and passing the Q
name or the Q name is a name from Q dot
XML and then you need to specify the
option to the tasks the options include
the parameters for the task and the URL
that's going to execute the task and the
easiest way to build up the task options
is to use task options builder you must
provide the URL that's going to execute
the task when you use task options stock
builder you just call the with URL
method and you pass the URL that's going
to execute the task then to add params
to the task you can just call the dot
pram method and pass in the params you
can have as many as you want here I've
just got to if your task doesn't have
any params and obviously you don't need
to do that you can write the code that
adds the task to the queue inside of a
transaction if you want and to do that
you specify the transaction as a very
first argument to Q dot ad when you're
using objectify you can just call the
offi dot get transaction method to get
the current transaction it's important
to understand that you can put the task
on the queue during a transaction so the
task only gets put on the queue if the
transaction is committed but the
execution of the task takes place
outside the transaction the tasks going
to be executed whenever the task gets to
the top of the queue whenever that
happens to be so long of course that the
transaction has already been committed
so let's take a look at the send
confirmation email servlet this servlet
has a do post method that sends an email
whenever anybody creates a conference
we're implementing it as a servlet
rather than as an endpoint function
because this functionality needs to be
completely internal to the application
we absolutely don't want anybody else to
trigger the sending of these emails
we've written the servlet for you you
can find the servlet in the lesson 5
folder if you want to we've already
defined it for you completely because
our goal here is not teach you how to
use email but to how to add a task to a
task queue however if you prefer you can
write it from scratch yourself and
actually I do recommend that you read
through this code because it does help
you learn how to send emails from App
Engine which is a cool thing to know how
to do so basically what we do is we get
the email out of the request we get the
information about the conference out of
the request then we create the body for
the email and include the information
about the conference that just got
created
we set the from field we add the
recipients we set the subject we set the
text and then here we send the email and
then we catch the exception in case the
email didn't get sent one thing to be
aware of it's a defense errors in your
code an email doesn't get sent you're
going to get an error in the log however
if the email doesn't get sent because
you've exceeded your email quota for the
day you're not going to get an error
here so if your email doesn't get sent
you might want to come and check your
quota for sending emails and you could
see the quota page shows you exactly how
many emails you've sent a good I've only
sent one so far today so you can add the
same confirmation email servlet to your
project as a done deal if you want but
then you do need to write the code to
schedule the task to add the task to the
task queue and to do that you're going
to need to update the create conference
function to add the send confirmation
email task to the default task queue and
you're going to be doing that yourself
first though I want to show you that you
can use the admin console to explore
your task queues so here in the task
queues page you can see the quote of
your task queues I've had one API call
go out the task queue so far you can see
the individual queues get listed I'm
only using the default Q so we only see
the default queue here so I drill down
into it and I have nothing in my queue
so I go to my application though and
create a conference so here I've created
this conference task queues everybody
now very quickly I'm going to go to the
admin console and update my task queues
page okay I wasn't quick enough to see
it running you can see that one task ran
in the last minute if I check my email I
see that I've got an email confirming
the conference I just created so we see
that might ask gran and it ran
successfully but I wonder what happens
if the task isn't successful so over
here in the create conference function
in conference API this is the code where
I add the task to the queue what I'm
going to do now is I'm going to change
the URL for the task to be a
non-existent URL so I've redeployed my
app it has an incorrect URL for the task
that's going to be execute
it when I create a conference so let's
just see my conference got created now
good let's go look at the task queues in
the admin console so now let's see what
happens when i refresh the task queues
viewer in admin console ok so now
looking down into the default qia
there's one task in the queue to a run
in the last minute it's running five per
second stroll down see over here there's
been three retries so far I'm just going
to leave that running just for a little
bit ok so far we've had nine retries
that's probably enough so I'm going to
go ahead and purge the queue to get this
task off the queue because it's never
going to complete it's important to
understand that when a task gets onto
the push queue and reaches the top of
the queue it's going to happen you're
going to keep trying to run it until it
actually succeeds if use all the default
options so it's really important to test
your cues so that you don't get some
task wedged in there that's never going
to finish but one other thing we can do
here is we can look in the logs and you
can see that we do have this report that
the task / send confirmation email and
score X that no handlers match this URL
so whenever you see that kind of error
no handle has match this URL that means
your apps trying to do something with a
URL that doesn't exist and that often
just means you've got a typo in your
code yeah and of course that never
happens you can actually choose a
different log level to show so here if
we should show warnings we very quickly
see the problem no handles match this
URL no handles match this URL it's
pretty easy here to see what the problem
was so I've shown you how to use the
task viewer in admin console and talked
about how to schedule the task now it's
your turn to write the code to send the
confirmation email whenever anybody
creates a new conference